hi and welcome to episode number 18 of
the weekly Google Club cut from podcast
I am Francisco and I'm here with my
colleague Mark Mandel hey Mark hey
friends sku doing pretty good very happy
to be back to California yeah you've
been absent about yeah I've been around
yeah exactly
so we've got some fun stuff today we are
talking to Ian Lewis about BigTable yes
should be pretty exciting and we have a
question of the week talking about some
new bits and pieces we announced
recently as well yeah how do you know
what you're allowed to do on the cloud
stuff like that how they make sure that
people don't do what they should not
yeah just making sure everything's
locked down and yeah and and I'm not
sure for etc but not really the question
but really the answer ok yeah yeah yeah
so it's gonna be pretty cool so but
before that so today right now like
today as on Wednesday especially if
you've downloaded this this episode as
it came out yeah so is actually one of
our big days for Google cloud platform
especially for Google developer advocate
definitely and because it is GCP next
the big Google cloud platform conference
yeah and and it's very cool it's
happening in San Francisco once a.m.
Thursday and if you can attend you
should definitely come see us because
we're gonna be hanging out somewhere
next to a sign that says podcast but if
you cannot come you can still catch up
with all the new things that we're going
to be announcing there's two ways one of
them we already mentioned it there was
what was the extended viewing parties
extended viewing parties the dead which
I'd like to make a short note on it has
grown a lot since last week I am very
impressed with a number of extended
parties that are happening yeah last
week we actually mentioned the fact that
there was some countries in Africa which
still it's pretty crazy they have a huge
amount of party which is really cool
massive but we're mentioning that there
was I think what country was it that had
more than the like the whole of Europe I
actually can't read it because there are
certain roads it's covering yeah
Cameroon Nigeria
yeah Nigeria has a crazy amount of
viewing parties and we mentioned that
Europe
did they have admit they didn't have as
many since then we got basically parties
in every single big city and I'm very
happy to say that Barcelona which he
said it was a little bit of a pity that
Barcelona they have a party cuz you know
I'm from there they have a party now it
has what about what about Sydney
Australia Australia male born Australian
general there's not a party I mean yes
is in the middle of the night but hey
yeah Japan if Japan can have party then
Australia can have a party I'm just I'm
a little I'm a little sad yeah I'm a
little bit heartbroken yeah but anyway
even for Australian people that are in
the middle of the night didn't know what
to do and they want to know more about
Google cloud platform there's also some
of our talks specially all the keynote
are going to be livestream you know you
can still catch up on the conference
through livestream just over the
internet yeah so if you're if you're
awake at that time wondering what to do
maybe you should tune in exactly I think
so actually if you're awake right now in
the middle of the night listening to
this podcast thank you thank you it's
very cool okay so let's go talk with our
colleague Ian Lewis that sounds like a
great idea we are very pleased today to
be joined by yet another of our
wonderful coworkers Ian Lewis thank you
so much for joining us today
yeah thanks for having me so in
it's great to have you here I know you
normally don't live anywhere near San
Francisco but why don't you tell us a
little bit about yourself what you do
accept cetera so everyone gets to know
you sure so I'm a developer advocate on
the Google cloud platform team and I I'm
actually based out of Tokyo Japan so I'm
normally spent most of my time over
there in and also in APEC so in the
asia-pacific region but I'm here at 4G
to be next so I'm you know in town for
the podcast so I can kind of hang out
here with you guys cool and just for
context iya Lewis from Japan you speak
very good English where you're from I'm
originally from Maryland actually from
the near DC so but I moved to Japan
about 10 years ago cool it's nice to
have someone from the United States for
instance of time in the podcast yeah we
have a lot of Japanese listeners that is
true can you say something in Japanese
for us to say hello to them konnichiwa
it or younger Eastham of it was quite
small that is very awesome
I heard Ian yeah it may be something
about your name or something yeah so
basically you know it's an introduction
cool excellent so so basically the idea
for the episode for today was since he
was two episodes ago that we got Paul we
talked about storage and we basically
covered the whole spectrum of storage
and this disguised about what product
you use when to use one or the other and
I think that the most interesting one or
at least one of the most interesting
products because it basically powers
Google is BigTable and it turns out that
you're pretty much the expert in the
team for about BigTable so could you
tell us a little bit about what is
BigTable for like I think it's called
10,000 I don't know yeah but from very
high level right so like there's quite a
difference you know like it's just five
thousand versus ten thousand four oh
yeah so so BigTable is a is a like
basically the no sequel database it was
the kind of the original one I started
the whole no sequel
idea and so Google's been using it for
quite a long time as the kind of go to
database for it's very large
applications like Gmail and search and
maps and it was originally published
kind of as a white paper and then the
ideas around the architecture of
BigTable were incorporated into open
source projects like HBase and Cassandra
and things like that and so from a
technical point of view it's kind of a
it's it's actually a key-value data
store but it allows you to have many
values per key and then it allows you to
do range scans by key so in kind of
relational database parlance it's you
have a primary index but you don't have
a secondary index so you can have many
you have what's basically called columns
but those columns you can't actually
index those so you can't do queries on
them and that sort of thing so when you
say you can do a range skin what does
that kind of look like okay so you can
kind of think of the keys in the in
BigTable as being sorted by the
lexographic lis basically and so they're
basically sorted and you can pick a key
and say okay from this key I want to do
a range scan of and then just basically
continue to iterate over those keys so
you can say get so from key a get 100
keys and then in that way you can do
things like paging or or whatnot cool
start out so you can kind of get
whatever is in that ordered range right
exactly
nice very interesting so these actually
sounds a little bit of a story about big
tables on something a bit like MapReduce
where basically Google writes a paper
and then someone else implements it not
right at Google so a I'm assuming HBase
is the open source implementation of a
table right exactly and so HBase was was
a open source project that was created
based on the bait table white paper and
but now that BigTable is something that
we are releasing as part of cloud
platform so that other people other
developers can use it we decided to
actually
make it available via the HBase API so
you can use the exact same API as HBase
in order to access BigTable which is
pretty powerful because you know big
table is completely fully managed and it
makes it really easy to you know to set
up and get running that is very cool I
really like the idea of Google creating
BigTable not open sourcing it and then
making it available and having to have
that the API to something that was
created from the favorite thing right I
really like open-source community these
things are funny well that's I think
that Google is kind of a modifying their
stance a little bit on that so like
things like tensorflow and kubernetes
are things that are kind of coming out
that people are where Google is actually
providing or creating an open-source
implementation that folks can kind of
build on rather than just releasing a
white paper from the white white tower
you know yeah yeah and I really like the
idea of now more like the paper comes
with code right nice very nice cool so I
mean I when I joined Google I joined as
a software engineer and and it's true
what you're saying basically everyone
uses BigTable for everything but if you
are not Google why could you use
BigTable okay so there's a few reasons
why you might want to use BigTable
so there's one is that BigTable is very
very fast you can make queries on
BigTable or gets inputs and things like
that both reads and writes in about less
than 10 milliseconds so it's a it's a
very fast database at the same time it's
also a database that will scale to very
large size so I mentioned that it's not
it's very limited and what it can
actually do like you only have primary
index or a primary key index and but
that those limits actually allow you to
scale to very very large sizes so things
like like a basically many petabytes in
size cool but there might be some use
cases where where you would want that
and that was that would be like things
like time series databases analytics
those are the ones that are very easy to
get started using to using BigTable cool
you said that
it was really fast and you actually gave
the the order of magnitude about 10
milliseconds for our listeners what is
the order of magnitude of others like do
you know for instance like datastore or
for instance on my sequel database so
MySQL will be pretty fast for things
like key basically getting by key or
selecting by key but for things like
very complex queries it could take you
know orders of magnitude longer like
many many seconds or many tens of
seconds or and things like datastore
generally come back in the tens of tens
of milliseconds or you know hundreds of
milliseconds depending on the queries
that you're actually doing so BigTable
is quite a bit faster and so in that
sense it's it's very good for kind of
more low latency applications and I'm
guessing you probably don't have similar
issues like you would with a my sequel
where is once a table gets really large
you start having like slowdowns and
stuff like that right exactly so so I
mentioned that MySQL will be fast for
keys you know selecting just a key but
it'll actually be get much slower when
it's like is actually you know
overloaded or it gets very large so
we're basically sort of thinking so
BigTable probably exists for those
really big data applications right
exactly
yeah there's actually one of my favorite
things that you can do with BigTable and
which we use for for a funny demo for pi
they it's the fact that you don't need
to know the whole key that you can just
say give me all the keys that starts
with these prefix right that works it is
pretty amazing yeah okay so say you can
be like oh like I'm us I'm actually just
storing like keys of like ten words but
if you give me only five I will still
find it because I can say give me all
the keys that start with those five
words five letters suffering right it is
pretty amazing so I mean I was able to
make it for my case but like that's a
very specific and weird thing to do to
search stuff on PI but have you ever
seen people doing this kind of things in
four
action in and what for so yeah that's a
great great thing to mention so big
table allows you to do several different
types of filters and one of those is a
prefix scan and so you can select all of
the the the keys that have a particular
prefix and so you might use that for
things like like indexing for instance
like in your case you actually indexed
numbers of pyrite yeah and then you can
go and search those later well you can
do the same sort of thing with text or
with with just regular old keys so this
is actually what data store uses to do
its secondary indexes for it when when
you actually save entities and things
like that
excellent so you could use like common
prefixes to group things together and
things like that
yes yes exactly cool so then I mean I
think that everybody then is convinced
that actually datastore is amazing and
yeah datastore sorry Big Dave was
amazing and every way everybody should
be using it but that's not the case even
at Google so why could someone not use
BigTable yeah so um there's a few
reasons and I mean these are the kind of
reasons why datastore exists so BigTable
doesn't actually support transactions so
it actually will support allowing you to
write a single row and in that that row
will be written or not written so in
that sense you can basically do
transactions on a single set of columns
or a single row but you can't actually
do that across rows so if you want to
save multiple rows at the same time you
need some other kind of transaction or
locking kind of mechanism it's also not
the greatest database for things like
high availability so if you have a
particular key that key may become a bit
unavailable kind of sporadically
depending on how that you know database
is being split up and moved around in
the backend and so so if you need your
your database to be like completely high
available highly available and for the
keys to be to be there all of the time
then database BigTable might not be
exactly what you want you also have the
the issue of it being local so it's a
local to a specific region and so you
can do replication to other regions in
the background or asynchronously but if
you need your database to be kind of
globally available or something like
that then then BigTable might not be
something that you you'll you'll want to
have go yeah that makes sense
what about the cost because how do you
pay for a big table is it like datastore
where you pay per operation or right so
big tables actually a little bit more
predictable than in datastore
so BigTable actually you pay for the
cost and then you pay for the nodes that
that are set up to allow you to make
queries on the database and that sort of
thing and so what you pay for is like
per hour per node and as well as the
storage in per gigabyte okay I don't
remember exactly what it is right now
but it's about the minimum cost for the
nodes is about $1,400 per month okay
plus storage so so you pay in that sense
and so I mentioned nodes and just that's
something that I think that I should
probably mention is that these there are
nodes that you set up in in BigTable
and you pay per node but these notes
basically provide you throughput into
the database so if you need to do you
basically get about 10,000 queries per
second per node and so if you need a lot
of more more than say 30,000 which is
the minimum three nodes is the minimum
if you need more than 30,000 then you
will set up more nodes and basically
allow you to do more throughput there so
really as as your throughput
requirements grow the more nerds you're
going to need therefore your cost
increases and you can try to separate
that off but what's interesting about
BigTable is that the nodes actually
don't store the data
data stored separately and so you can
kind of increase and decrease the number
of note it's like pretty a you know
separately from how much data you store
so say you know you have a lot of data
but you don't actually need that many
QPS you can actually just have a three
nodes and you know your storage can be
astronomically big but you know you're
just using three nodes taxes eight and
whatwhat is that that there's a minimum
of three nodes so minimum so the the
minimum of three nodes is basically
there so that to allow a little bit of
redundancy for the nodes because those
can be kind of moved around a little bit
also but but basically like the when you
create a cluster a big table cluster
essentially you have a minimum of three
nodes to set up and and so that's
basically kind of a way of allowing it
kind of a minimal level of service for
BigTable okay so something that I used
for for the PI finder for that demo was
actually that idea of being able to add
a note and remove them and I was lucky
enough that I got to talk to work with
the BigTable team so I run a data flow
process where I was processing a huge
amount of data
I mean pi is big and on top of that I
was storing everything to big table at
the same time so I had I was able to run
a big table cluster with 500 notes yeah
that that was my awesome incredible be
amazing I had like I think is like over
1,000 nodes in data flow trying to
basically write as much as I could
directly to be table and BigTable didn't
even shake that was that what were you
getting do you know I actually I didn't
look all the time at it but I know that
it passed really really fast 1 million
requests per second really really easily
and that was like oh wow and yeah and
and then the good thing is that once I
was done and I had all Pi story in
BigTable I took it down to three and
everything went really fast right which
is really nice because then it's like oh
yeah I'm done
I have my process already done like if
you're running MapReduce or whatever
once the MapReduce is over if you need
to wait from it you don't need those no
to have like all the nodes you had at
the beginning that's really cool yeah
you know that's one benefit of me being
on the same team it's life I've seen the
same exact things that you guys have but
yeah I was I think the the graph was
actually about close to two million two
million which is pretty impressive yeah
but one in two million I mean like yeah
you can you can also say that but that
we do have customers that are that do
quite a bit more than that so it's a
it's it's a database that scales I mean
we I mean internally we also have like
you know customers that do very very
large amounts of queries per second so
and I also mentioned that it's it's like
10 milliseconds per per query but like
that basically doesn't change like no
matter the size of the data as well as
like you know that's also like a p99
type of thing so like you know if you
basically 99% of the queries will be you
know faster than 10 milliseconds so like
it's very very consistent in terms of
like how how fast the queries are which
is you know very advantageous for a lot
of use cases cool ok so let's imagine
that I wanted to use BigTable but I'm
actually being I'm using something
different now like for instance I'm
using datastore how big of a change
could that be for the developer yeah
that could be quite a big change it
depends on what you're doing with with
datastore if you're doing things that
are very kind of low-level where you're
only doing gets inputs by key then that
can translate pretty pretty easily to
BigTable and so I think it wouldn't be
too hard to migrate but other things
where you're doing lots of queries and
you're do using lots of indexes those
types of situations would be pretty
difficult to move over I think and what
about if I was already using HBase and I
wanted to use BigTable so that's a good
question so BigTable does support the
HBase API there's a few kind of edge
cases where it that that it doesn't
support those are mostly around managing
the HBase so like doing compactions and
you know
nodes and things like that and BigTable
is kind of fully managed so you don't
really have to deal with any of that but
there are a few like kind of small edge
cases where you can't that that it
doesn't support but for the most part it
supports of the the wide the majority of
the HPC API and so it's very very easy
to like move from an HBase installation
or an HBase cluster over to BigTable
probably the hardest thing will be
moving the data over okay
that's fair enough okay well before we
wrap up here um is there anything about
BigTable you want to mention or anything
else that we many may have managed to
miss any cool project that you could
like to mention that you've seen before
all of that other than and might think
searching for pie I'm sure that people
have the more interesting stuff than
searching by um so Google has made quite
a lot of cool projects so and all of
them pretty much use BigTable but um
what I think is BigTable interesting
about BigTable is that it's used kind of
at Google as the basis for a lot of
other types of data stores and so things
like datastore cloud and cloud datastore
are kind of built on top of big table to
allow like secondary indexes and things
like that so I think that like how big
table is used kind of is a is a
low-level kind of storage is pretty
interesting and I think that just just
the sheer scale and the the amount of
work that's gone into it at Google is
quite a quite amazing
we've spent probably about a year and
like millions of man-hours improving
BigTable and so it's very very optimized
when you compare it to things like HBase
and Cassandra like Cassandra can do
things like you can write very fast but
it can't read very fast and but BigTable
can kind of do both and so it's very
very interesting that it can read really
fast and write really fast and get
really big so it's almost like this like
magical thing that's that we've been
able to improve and build upon over the
last you know 10 years or so awesome oh
and thank you so much for joining us
really appreciate you taking the time
yeah it's been great thank you
thanks thanks so much to Anne for
joining us for that interview I learned
a whole lot I really didn't actually
know very much at all that big table and
now I have a much better idea
ya know big big day was a very very cool
product and it is pretty amazing yeah
yeah yeah once you get started and you
start using it and I have not seen the
point where it's like oh yeah it's not
slow enough nope not there yet no
excellent okay so but we do have a very
interesting question of the week the
question kinda comes from managing say a
Google cloud platform project and within
that project you probably have a bunch
of different things like maybe you have
stuff deploy to App Engine stuff to push
into cloud storage maybe stuff on
compute engine instances and you have
someone you join your team and you want
them to say okay I want them to be able
to deploy say compute engine instances
but I don't want them to be able to read
from say cloud storage maybe you have
like private keys there or something
like that there are only limited to
certain team members can you do that
well no until today actually yeah until
today until today until today right now
Wednesday March 23rd 2013 yeah that's it
I'm really bad with we date yeah yeah so
actually today we announce this really
cool thing which is cloud I am I am or
cloud I am or cloud iam if you want to
pronounce it now we're wait so cloud
identity and access management if you
want to be correct yes yes yeah and
basically what it allows you is - it
allows you to talk about basically you
talk about what things are people
allowed to do yeah so so far we had
three roles in Google cloud platform we
had the role of honor that was basically
a lot to do anything yep
the role of editor that was allowed to
do some things most things most things
but not everything yeah and then the
role of viewer that was allowed just to
view things but not like create an
instance if I'm like very limited yeah
so if I if I wanted to grant someone
access they pretty much got access to
mostly all of it
basically so now you are you can
actually create way more roles and we
already did that we created a bunch of
different roles so for instance you can
say oh actually someone is gonna be a
compute engine instance administrator so
that person will be allowed to create
instances to delete them if needed but
they will not be able to modify a Google
Cloud Storage bucket for instance so you
can really sort of tailor exactly what
permission levels people have within the
system to exactly what your business
needs are exactly and that building on
top of the of the best practice of using
multiple projects for different
environments you could see something
where you can have like four vacuum
environment like production product QA
product test product and you have
different roles for those people so
someone will be able to do like
everybody will be an honor and be
allowed to do everything in the project
for test but maybe in QA you can do all
of those things and maybe production
your able not to do anything unless you
are def ups and then you are actually
about actually allowed to take down
instances and delete data and do crazy
things like that no I said I'm guessing
you could probably also like build tools
as well so like you can't physically go
in and modify stuff but if you go
through the administration console like
a custom built thing or like some DevOps
type scripting or environment then
you're like okay that's okay
but then it sort of mitigates how much
problems you can really kind of yeah you
can kind of do by just kind of poking
around and seeing what sort of things
happen when I put a spanner in the
electrical socket yeah you should not do
that hates that yeah on top of that
there's also the fact that when I say at
entity aid can it sounds like it's only
for people but not only you can have the
same thing for for instances or any kind
of machines but by using service
accounts so you can basically say oh
this instance is allowed to read from
these classes up from this bucket or
this instance is able to so you know
like we we used to have those things as
as tokens yeah you you can have the same
granularity of oh sorry not talking
scopes yeah for us to you have this kind
of same idea for
for every single one of the roles
applied to every single one of the
resources okay so not only can you
really nail it down by user but you can
be like yeah this part could only access
this particular part that's definitely
access to this particular part you can
get much more secure about it yeah
basically you get all the enhance
security that a company like Google
could need like until now it could have
been really weird to have some like a
big big company where in a big big
company you can trust every single
engineer to do every single thing yep
now you can actually write it down yeah
you know so yeah very excited about this
and very excited about see how people
welcome it I'm pretty sure that there
was a lot of people waiting for this so
I think so too
I'm pretty sure there's someone someone
there listening to this pot that's right
now just cheering yes I I was talking to
a listener recently who said they almost
crashed that car through an app for
manifest here today because they threw
their hands in the air and did not grab
the steering wheel
was it the kubernetes one it was the
kubernetes one yes so people it is
dangerous otherwise wonderful well
Francis thank you very much for joining
us for yet another episode thank you
very much for having me very happy to be
here and let's see what's coming next
week ooh maybe we'll have something
special I mean we're a Google cloud
platform next today right now we are
indeed
maybe something special will come next
week we shall see until like 6:00